[Music]
hey guys it's me jasmine and today we're
going to be making some of bts's
favorite foods they're honestly a bunch
of foodies with a lot of favorite foods
they love panda express mcdonald's but
today we'll be focusing on some of their
favorite korean eats like korean knife
cut noodles kimchi stew a delicious and
refreshing cold noodle seafood and a few
different types of korean bbq so let's
get started we're going to start with rm
the leader of the group one of his
favorite foods is kagupsu korean knife
cut noodle soup i couldn't find
specifically which variation of kaguksu
that he really likes so i'm doing a
quick basic version of the korean knife
cut noodle soup so to this pot of water
i'm gonna add my anchovies and my kelp
and we're just gonna bring this to a
simmer over medium heat then we're gonna
add in our zucchini our carrots and our
shiitake mushrooms and we're just gonna
let that cook for like four to five more
minutes and set it to the side if you're
able to make a kelp and anchovy broth
beforehand with either a cold water soak
or a lukewarm water soak that'll really
help enrich the flavor of the broth but
since we're doing a quick and easy
kagusu this will do just fine i've gone
ahead and gotten some pre-made fresh
knife cut noodles from the store you can
also buy them dry really up to you
buying pre-made noodles will save you
about an hour in the kitchen but if you
have the time i really encourage you to
try making them they're super fun so
satisfying to cut the noodles but let's
get to cooking the noodles i'm gonna
give it a little stir to keep them from
sticking to each other and once these
noodles are done i'm just gonna run them
under some cold water to stop the
cooking process now it's time to put
everything together i am going to serve
mine in a stone pot so i'm just heating
that up real quick now i'm gonna add
some noodles that we just boiled and
then top it with the broth that we made
earlier for toppings do everything to
taste but i'm gonna do chopped green
thai chili some red chili some garlic
and some soy sauce it's so pretty it's
like so simple yeah it's so
delicious last but not least we're gonna
just add some salt to taste i like
sodium it's my favorite food group and
some black pepper time to eat babe do
you want to come try this with me sort
of long-ass noodles yes
oh the noodles are so silky it's very
garlicky it's got a great cake it feels
like a very clean broth i can't get over
the soup it's so good
let's move on to jamin one of his
favorite foods is kimchi stew otherwise
known as kimchije in a pot i'm gonna add
some vegetable oil over high heat let
that heat up and then add in your onions
your garlic and your pork belly until
the onions are softened and the pork
belly is slightly browned now let's go
ahead and add our kimchi but reserve the
juices and we're just gonna let that
cook together for a few minutes until
the kimchi has turned this dark red
beautiful color yeah this smells really
good
can you enjoy food too much
do you see this beautiful reddish brown
color so now we can add in our korean
chili flakes sugar
salt kimchi juice our anchovy and kelp
broth that i pre-made and give that a
good stir i'm gonna layer in some tofu
then i'm gonna add in my shiitake
mushrooms i prefer to add in the tofu
and mushrooms sooner rather than later
because i like the flavor of the stew to
actually infuse into these babies just
going to give this a quick little stir
and then i'm going to cover this and let
it simmer for about 30 minutes i don't
actually have a lid for this so this is
the next best thing
is done it looks amazing it's literally
still bubbling because the pot is
keeping it nice and hot i'm gonna top
mine with some green onions i like a lot
it's not even that much more great all
of it yeah some sesame oil and it's time
to dig in babe we got another one
oh wow that's so good dare i say i i
have outdone myself no i think that's
pretty fair to say
so good let's move on to the next one
one of his favorite foods is korean
marinated short ribs also called kirby i
have my short ribs here that i prepped
by soaking in cold water for about 30
minutes just to get rid of any bone
fragments this one's super easy to make
we pretty much just need to make the
marinade so i have my blender here we're
just going to add in our pear onion
ginger garlic soy sauce water brown
sugar honey sesame oil and we're just
gonna blend that until it's nice and
smooth now i'm gonna pour it over my
short ribs that pear in there serves a
very important function it helps break
down the meats a little bit to make them
nice and tender now i'm just gonna make
sure that all the ribs are evenly coated
and we're gonna put this in the fridge
and let it marinate for at least four
hours preferably overnight our short
ribs are done marinating so let's go
ahead and start cooking
i'm using this round kbq grill obviously
you don't need one if you have a
non-stick pan that's more than fine
we're in for a ride kirby is so good
there's like this cartilage around the
bone that if you knot on oh my god all
your primal instincts through the roof
man all right our grill is nice and hot
let's go ahead and place our short ribs
on the grill so one thing with cooking
carving with a non-stick pan is that
there's no drainage hole like there is
here it can lead to boiling your meat
which is like it's fine but it's just
not as bomb so a hack is to take a paper
towel clamp it with your tongs and kind
of wipe away the sauce if it's really
coming high these are looking amazing
let's go ahead and flip them
oh yeah
another one
and another one
all right i think you get it by now and
as they finish up cooking you can just
cut them in between the bones once the
meat is cooked to your liking it's
pretty much done for plating i'm laying
down the meat on a small bed of onions
that'll help soak up any excess
oils always serve yourself more than
they do at restaurants that is the dream
okay so now all i need to do is top it
with some
green onions
i love her she looks so ready to be
eaten okay let's dig in
oh my god you've outdone yourself
it's like sweet garlicky umamiyi okay
next one korean bbq continues this one
is frugogi one of j hope's favorite
foods and is one of the most popular
types of korean bbq meats as well
honestly it's one of the ones that you
just can never go wrong with i have
three pounds of thinly sliced ribeye
steak here same thing as the caribbean
it's very easy to make all we need to do
is just make the marinade all right so
in a blender we are just going to
combine our onions our asian pear 10
cloves of garlic ginger brown sugar soy
sauce sesame oil and black pepper then
we're going to blend it up all right our
marinade looks nice and smooth let's
pour the marinade over the beef toss in
our sliced white onion and green onions
now we're just going to mix it up with
our hands make sure everything is evenly
coated and then we're going to throw
this in the fridge to marinate for at
least an hour but again preferably
overnight the meat is done marinating
and it's time to cook
i'm using my grill again but you can use
a non-stick skillet no problem don't
overcrowd your pan it'll lead to boiled
porgo
not bomb very sad finally we're just
going to top it with some green onions
and some sesame seeds
cheers
oh mmm
i like my chocolate beef i feel like
char really makes
extra delicious
can't go wrong with it next food
this is grilled pork belly and is one of
suga's favorite foods there's not really
much to prep here besides making the
sauces this sauce over here is samjang
it's a popular korean dipping sauce it's
salty it's sweet it's got a fermented
soybean paste in there i've been told
many times actually that is very funky
smelling but when people eat it it's
umami heaven i'm telling you there's
also another very popular dipping sauce
super easy it's literally just salt
sesame oil and pepper once you heat up
your grill we can get to putting the
pork belly so first what i like to do is
take a piece of the pork take it fat
side down and just kind of rub it all
over
the grill so we're going to cook the
pork until it's browned on both sides
fun fact this is called sam gupta and it
translates pretty much to three layered
meat and it refers to you know how it
looks the fat the meat the fat good
stuff this is like such a popular meat
to order at korean barbecue the only
qualm i have with this is that it takes
too long to cook i can't wait that long
it's like cooking right in front of you
and you just have to wait all right
let's give these a flip whoa
oh my goodness
oh yeah if it's not crispy like this i
don't know what you're doing man this is
the way to eat it let's plate this i'm
gonna pair it with some perilla leaves
red leaf lettuce sliced jalapenos sliced
garlic and we have our pork belly some
super crispy some moderately crispy and
of course our sauces the samjang and the
salt pepper sesame oil honestly i'm so
grateful to be looking at this platter
it's beautiful life's what you make it
so let's make it rock did anyone get
that reference am i too old let's eat
let's make our sam which is a wrap i
like the red leaf lettuce okay
cheers so bomb
next one this is one of jyn's favorite
foods and it's a korean cold noodle
called naengmyun let's get started with
a broth in a pot i'm gonna add my flank
steak green onions white onions dried
seaweed ginger
garlic
rice wine
soup soy sauce korean beef stock also
called tashida
sugar sea salt black pepper and water
i'm going to bring this to a boil and
then let it simmer for an hour all right
so the broth is cooled to room
temperature i've taken out the beef link
to let that chill as well so here in
this other pot i have put a few layers
of cheesecloth over it and i am going to
take the broth that we made earlier and
pour over it so i really want a super
clean and smooth broth so that's why i'm
using a few layers these cloth is going
to be able to catch all the black
peppers so the broth is going to be
super super smooth look at how
beautifully smooth and clean this broth
is i chilled it and now i'm going to add
my water radish kimchi brine a lot of
korean locals love it so cold that
they'll put ice to make it oh super
super cold i recommend it now that our
broth is done we just need to boil the
noodles so this dish does use a specific
type of noodle these are naengmyun
noodles and it's like a buckwheat sweet
potato hybrid they boil super fast like
two to three minutes and they are done i
am going to strain these run them under
cold water until they are nice and cold
and then we can get to assembling the
noodles are done i'm gonna go ahead and
place them into the center of our bowl
now i'm gonna pour some broth around the
noodles then top it with a few slices of
the beef link we use to make the broth
pickled radish cucumbers half a
hard-boiled egg and toasted sesame seeds
that is so refreshing oh wow next dish
all right let's move on to changu and
one of his favorite foods is
which you might already know as sashimi
koreans call it hue and really the main
difference is that sashimi is served
with soy sauce and wasabi and hue is
commonly served with this vinegar red
chili paste called cho gochujang more
colloquially referred to as chojam same
word just a little bit shortened here's
my platter we have a variety platter
here tuna salmon and halibut the only
thing missing is our cho dang so let's
make that and i'm going to add a quarter
cup of gochujang which is a korean red
chili paste two tablespoons of water two
tablespoons of rice vinegar two
tablespoons of sugar one teaspoon of
minced garlic and one teaspoon of
toasted sesame seeds now we're just
gonna mix our sauce until it's well
combined be careful when mixing because
the chili paste is pretty thick so it
sloshes around and i like pretty much
always spill
not today though today we're winning i
feel like i'm gonna jinx myself some
people like their paste thicker some
people like it thinner if you want your
sauce to be thicker just add less water
great now that this is well combined
let's grab our platter again i am so
freaking excited because this is also
one of my favorite foods let's freakin
dig in alright so a few ways to eat this
we can wrap it in the red leaf lettuce
the perilla leaf or just eat it with
rice
chunky you've got great taste okay
cheers
all right i'm gonna try to get this
right okay
well now i have to try that too
all right guys that was a lot of food we
had today a lot of traditional korean
eats noodles noodle soups kimchi jjigae
korean bbq of all sorts and even seafood
which one was your favorite today
definitely the cowbee what about you i
mean one of my favorite foods is sushi
and sashimi so obviously the what well
let us know in the comments below what
dish you think looks the tastiest and if
you make any of them make sure to snap a
picture and tag me on instagram because
i want to see and also if you want to
learn more about bts's favorite foods
make sure to check out my friend
joelle's video on buzzfeed video where
she eats like bts for a week and bts if
you're watching you know you should hit
me up i know how to make all your
favorite foods come hang out i'll cook
for you let's eat goodbye
see ya
oh yes
you